[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what's going on it's all right Space
Ranger it's a code 546. you mean it's a
yes and he's a oh yeah
Majesty
[Music]
a literal
s for his leading star debut Nice Guy
Tom Hanks would become the king of
yuppies 80s slapstick starring in
Classics like big tuned in audiences up
to that point knew him primarily from
the two season ABC Sitcom Bosom Buddies
and Justice hanks's obvious Talent
couldn't be contained a television it
was likewise apparent he wouldn't always
be stuck doing just comedies
Philadelphia represented his first foray
into drama leading straight into a best
actor Oscar win most importantly it gave
a harrowing human face to the AIDS
epidemic that American Society at large
had struggled or refused to fully
comprehend at that point during his
Oscar acceptance speech he referenced
mentors and peers who were gay and who
would influenced his life in recent
years much of Hanks is Acclaim in
accolades has been directed at his
biopics think Captain Phillips Saving Mr
Banks and a beautiful day in the
neighborhood so with all of that out of
the way let's take a look at the one
who's been referred to as America's dad
as we count down our list of the best
Tom Hanks movies
[Music]
pretend that Thing You Do
Willie band manager Mr White helps a
small town band achieve Big Time success
when they release a beetle style pop
song in 1964. Pennsylvania banned the
Wonders become a sensation after their
drummer breaks his arm and is replaced
by Jazz Enthusiast guy Patterson who
injects something a bit different into
their music starring Tom Everett Scott
Liv Tyler Jonathan check and Tom Hanks
who also directed the film critics say a
light sweet and thoroughly entertaining
debut for director Tom Hanks that Thing
You Do makes up and charm what it lacks
in complexity Wolfman thank you very
much you're a good man Scott Pell give
me a call later on the week we'll do
something
the Wonders are in breach
and tract
sorry I'm really sorry Mr White
well don't worry no one's going to
prison son
it's a very common Tale
well maybe for you but I was in a band
and we still have a hit record
yeah you do one hit wonders
it's a very common Tale
my first time in a real recording studio
you want to hang around for a while okay
by me
but you're out of the hotel this
afternoon
you can't help that
no guy Horus was right about you you
aren't the smart one
mine Saving Private Ryan Captain John
Miller takes his Men Behind Enemy Lines
to find private James Ryan whose Three
Brothers have been killed in combat
surrounded by the brutal realities of
War while searching for Ryan each man
embarks upon a personal journey and
discovers their own strength to triumph
over an uncertain future with honor
decency and courage starring Tom Hanks
Edward Burns Matt Damon and directed by
Steven Spielberg critics say anchored by
another winning performance from Tom
Hanks Steven Spielberg's unflinchingly
realistic War film virtually redefines
the genre I have my orders too sir they
don't include me abandoning my post I
understand that but this changes things
I don't see that it does sir
the chief of staff for the United States
Army says it does sir our orders are to
hold this bridge at all costs our planes
in the 82nd had taken out every bridge
across the murderet with the exception
of two one of the loan and this one here
we let the Germans take it we're going
to lose our foothold and have to display
private your outfit wants to stay that's
one thing
your party's over here sir I can't leave
until at least reinforcements you got
three minutes to gather your gear sir
what about them I mean there's barely
hardly enough
two of our guys already died trying to
find you all right
that's right
number eight Captain Phillips
in April 2009 the U.S container ship
Mayors Alabama sails towards its
destination on a day that seems like any
other suddenly Somali pirates race
toward the vessel climb aboard and take
everyone hostage the captain of the ship
Richard Phillips looks to protect his
crew from the Hostile Invaders and their
leader Muse the Pirates are after
millions of dollars and Phillips must
use his wits to make sure everyone
survives and returns home safely
starring Tom Hanks Catherine Keener
barcata D and directed by Paul
Greengrass critics say smart powerfully
acted and Incredibly intense Captain
Phillips offers film goers a Hollywood
biopic done right and offers Tom Hanks a
showcase for yet another brilliant
performance
there are one mile now cap only one mile
Coalition warship 237 this is mask
Alabama Coalition warship 237 mask
Alabama
go Alabama opposition
0.5
inspired by two pirate skits with a
possible Mothership following we require
immediate assistance
we have a crew of 20 we are preparing
our weapons down but request as
supportive possible
number seven a beautiful day in the
neighborhood
Lloyd Vogel is an investigative
journalist who receives an assignment to
profile Fred Rogers aka Mr Rogers he
approaches the interview with skepticism
as he finds it hard to believe that
anyone can have such a good nature for
rogers's empathy kindness and decency
soon chips away at vogel's jaded outlook
on life forcing the reporter to
reconcile with his own painful past
starring Tom Hanks Matthew Reese Susan
kolecki Watson and directed by Marielle
Heller critics say much like the Beloved
TV personality that inspired it a
beautiful day in the neighborhood offers
a powerfully affecting message about
acceptance and understanding
holy crap
Andrea hi Fred such a pleasure to
finally see you oh can I take this for
you thank you hello Miss Rogers
hello
hi Kevin hello I hope you and I can be
friends Sunday
Mr Vogel
may I call you Jerry
yes sir you certainly may
Lord Joanne adored your article as did I
Andrea are you feeling better about
daycare
a little
Maybe
good I'm not the only one who talks to
Fred
number six Apollo 13.
this Hollywood drama is based on the
events of the Apollo 13 lunar Mission
astronauts Jim Lavelle Fred Hayes and
Jack swigger find everything going
according to plan after leaving Earth's
orbit however when an oxygen tank
explodes the scheduled moon landing is
called off subsequent tensions within
the crew and numerous technical problems
threaten both the astronaut survival and
their safe return to earth starring Tom
Hanks Bill Paxton Kevin Bacon and
directed by Ron Howard critics say in
recreating the troubled space mission
Apollo 13 pulls no punches it's a
masterfully told drama from director Ron
Howard bolstered by an ensemble of solid
performances
and then if you could uh give your
oxygen tanks a stir
Roger that
[Music]
hey we've got a problem here
what did you do nothing I stirred the
tanks whoa
hey
this is Houston uh say again please
Houston we have a problem
if you can
Frank Abagnale Jr worked as a doctor a
lawyer and as a co-pilot for a major
airline all before his 18th birthday a
master of deception he was also a
brilliant forger whose skill gave him
his first real claim to fame at the age
of 17. Frank Abagnale Jr became the most
successful bank robber in the history of
the United States FBI agent Carl
Hanratty makes it his Prime mission to
capture Frank and bring him to justice
but Frank is always one step ahead of
him starring Leonardo DiCaprio Tom Hanks
Christopher Walken and directed by
Steven Spielberg critics say with help
from a strong performance by Leonardo
DiCaprio as real-life wonderkin con
artist Frank Abagnale Steven Spielberg
crafts a film that's stylish breezly
entertaining and surprisingly sweet
I wouldn't lie to you
[Music]
you're wearing a wedding ring call you
lied to me about that did you lied about
that you asked me if I had a family I
did but I don't anymore
[Music]
yes no no no there's no problem we're
coming out right now
well that was good that was good what
did you you pay some Hotel desk clerk to
make that call for you is that what you
did it's Captain Lou
I've got one minute to bring you out
can Luke Oh Captain Luke well Carl I
gotta say that that sounds pretty
official to me but like I said I I think
it's just me and you here
you're gonna have to catch me right
Frank you have to trust me on this these
people have been embarrassed Frank
they're angry you rob their Banks you
steal their money you live in their
country I told you this was what was
going to happen
that there was no other way for it to
end
don't make a mistake
number four big
after a wish turns 12-year-old Josh
Baskin into a 30 year old man he heads
to New York City and gets a low-level
job at MacMillan toy company a chance
encounter with the owner of the company
leads to a promotion testing new toys
soon a fellow employee Susan Lawrence
takes a romantic interest in Josh
however the pressure of living as an
adult begins to overwhelm him and he
longs to return to his simple former
life as a boy starring Tom Hanks
Elizabeth Perkins Robert Loggia and
directed by Penn Marshall critics say
refreshingly sweet and undeniably funny
big is a showcase for Tom Hanks who
dives into his role and infuses it with
charm and surprising poignancy
hi all right
all the same people having all the same
discussion it's like they cloned some
party in 1983 and kept spinning it out
again and again and again
I loved your ideas on the squeezy doll
line
it's Beluga
McMillan orders it every year
[Music]
silence
all right
okay you want a glass of water
you need something to drink because I
have a milkshake or something
number three Toy Story 3. with their
beloved Andy preparing to leave for
college Woody Buzz Lightyear Jessie and
the rest of the toys find themselves
headed for the attic but mistakenly wind
up on the curb with the trash Woody's
quick thinking saves a gang but all but
Woody end up being donated to a daycare
center unfortunately the uncontrollable
kids do not play nice so Woody and the
Gang make plans for a Great Escape
starring Tom Hanks Tim Allen Joan Cusack
and directed by Lee ankrich critics say
definitely blending comedy adventure and
honest emotion Toy Story 3 is a rare
second sequel that really works
see daylight we're gonna be okay
I don't think that's daylight
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
go go hit the button hurry
[Music]
where's your kid now Sheriff no no
number two Toy Story 2. Woody has stolen
from his home by toy dealer Al mcwigan
leaving Buzz Lightyear and the rest of
the gang to try to rescue him but when
Woody discovers that he's actually a
valuable collectible from a once popular
television show called Woody's Roundup
and is reunited with his horse Bullseye
Jesse The Yodeling cowgirl and his
faithful sidekick Stinky Pete the
prospector he doesn't want to leave
starring Tom Hanks Tim Allen Joan Cusack
and directed by Ash Brannon John
Lasseter and Lee Anchorage critics say
the rare sequel that arguably improves
on its predecessor Toy Story 2 uses
inventive storytelling gorgeous
animation and a talented cast to deliver
another Rich movie-going experience for
all ages wait wait wait wait wait what
about the gold mine and the cute little
critters of the dynamite there was a
great show I mean why cancel it two
words spot Nick once the astronauts went
up children only wanted to play with
space toys I know how that feels but
still my own show I mean look at all
this stuff didn't you know why your
valuable property I wish the guys could
see this hey howdy hey that's me I'm on
a yo-yo
ah hey nice teeth
still a good looking guy
oh it's a bag cool
what are you you push the hat and out oh
outcome bubbles clever
I got it there's a snake in my boot oh
hey Bullseye go along go long
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
Philadelphia
fearing it would compromise his career
lawyer Andrew Beckett hides his
homosexuality and HIV status at a
powerful Philadelphia Law Firm but his
secret is exposed when a colleague spots
the illnesses Telltale lesions fired
shortly afterwards Beckett resolves to
sue for discrimination teaming up with
Joe Miller the only lawyer willing to
help in court they face one of his
ex-employers top litigators Belinda
Connie starring Tom Hanks Denzel
Washington Jason Roberts and directed by
Jonathan Demi critics say Philadelphia
indulges in some unfortunate cliches and
its quest to impart a meaningful message
but it's Stellar casts and sensitive
direction are more than enough to
compensate excuse me Charles
without due respect this
this is preposterous it doesn't make any
sense well you're right Beckett you
don't have an attitude problem take it
easy Walter if you had lost confidence
in me why'd you give me the Highline
suit Andy you nearly blew the entire
case for Christ's sakes that alone is
inexcusable
it's traffic for us
uh-huh
so you were concealing your illness
that's correct
all right explain this to me like I'm a
two-year-old okay because there's an
element to this thing I just cannot get
through my thick head
didn't you have an obligation to tell
your employer you had this dreaded
deadly infectious disease
that's not the point from the day they
hired me to the day I was fired I served
my clients consistently thoroughly with
absolute Excellence if they hadn't fired
me that's what I'd be doing today
Castaway
obsessively punctual FedEx executive
Chuck Nolan is enroute to an assignment
in Malaysia when his plane crashes over
the Pacific Ocean during a storm the
sole survivor of the flight Chuck washes
ashore on a deserted island when his
efforts to sail away and contact help
fail he learns how to survive on the
island where he remains for years
accompanied by only his handmade
volleyball friend Wilson will Chuck ever
return to civilization and reunite with
his loved ones starring Tom Hanks Helen
Hunt Nick Searcy and directed by Robert
zemeckis critics say flawed but
fascinating Castaway offers an
intelligent script some of Robert
zemeckis's most mature directing and his
showcase performance from Tom Hanks
well then
well done
[Applause]
[Applause]
like that I'm coming
who's that
Bridge of spies
during the Cold War the Soviet Union
captures U.S pilot Francis Gary Powers
after shooting down his U2 spy plane
sentenced to 10 years in prison Powers
his only hope as New York lawyer James
Donovan recruited by a CIA operative to
negotiate his release Donovan boards a
plane to Berlin hoping to win the young
man's Freedom through a prisoner
exchange if all goes well the Russians
would get Rudolph Abel the convicted Spy
Who Donovan defended in court starring
Tom Hanks Mark rylance Alan Alda and
directed by Steven Spielberg critics say
Bridge of spies finds new life in
Hollywood's classic Cold War Espionage
Thriller formula thanks to reliably
outstanding work from Steven Spielberg
and Tom Hanks this is not an equitable
trade sir
but what you're saying is if Powers has
given up everything he knows then Moscow
would trade
why wouldn't they
as for Abel if he dies in an American
prison the next Russian operative who
gets caught might think twice about
keeping his mouth shut and you never
know Abel might want to see the sky
again
and decide to trade Russian secrets for
small American favors
how can we know this
we little man
we just do our jobs like Lieutenant
Powers he's just a pilot
Toy Story
Woody a good-hearted Cowboy doll Who
belongs to a young boy named Andy sees
his position as Andy's favorite toy
jeopardized when his parents buy him a
Buzz Lightyear action figure even worse
The Arrogant Buzz thinks he's a real
Spaceman on a mission to return to his
home planet when Andy's family moves to
a new house Woody and Buzz must escape
the clutches of maladjusted neighbors
Sid Phillips and reunite with their boy
starring Tom Hanks Tim Allen Don Rickles
and directed by John Lasseter critics
say entertaining as it is innovative Toy
Story reinvigorated animation while
heralding the arrival of Pixar as a
family-friendly force to be reckoned
with
double bass talk
I can see your windows strong
well we have ways of making talk
where are your Rebel friends now
[Music]
all right
foreign
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I'm your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]